[Music]
this is the Taiwan Strait in recent
years China has sent military aircraft
across the street and towards the island
Southwest on a need daily basis
repeatedly testing taiwan's ability to
respond to an invasion along its West
Coast but this year China began doing
something new in April and May Chinese
aerial drones went further than ever
before encircling the entire Island and
fighter jets were detected on the
Island's East Coast military experts say
Taiwan has always relied on its
mountainous terrain as a natural shield
in the event of an attack looking to its
East as a safe place to refuel and
re-arm its fighter jets if the West
Coast fell so China's growing range has
led to competing ideas amongst the
Island's current and former military
leaders about how Taiwan should respond
Terran cannot protect ourselves anymore
compared to the decades ago
how serious are these threats to
taiwan's east coast and does the Ireland
need to change its strategy
a key part of taiwan's current strategy
can be found here
this satellite imagery shows an Air
Force Base on the Island's East that's
over 30 years old bunkers build deep
into the mountains store fighter jets
and anti-ship missiles like these that
could launch in response to an attack on
the main infrastructure in taiwan's West
by Sheltering these weapons in the
mountains Taipei plans to be able to
prevent China from Gaining early control
of the Skies experts say this is crucial
because the people's Liberation Army of
China dwarfs taiwan's military limiting
the Island's capacity to defend against
a full-scale Invasion From China on its
own instead its main strategy has been
to survive in the East until allies
including the US can arrive to assist
the island
but some experts say China's recent
incursions to the islands East and its
growing military prowess are making
taiwan's current strategy outdated you
can see the developments in the
modernization of the proa they have a
lot of the measure and the capability
attack from the Eastern side so East
SanSai is not the same as we thoughts
here decades ago
retired Admiral Lisi Minh served for
more than 40 years in taiwan's Armed
Forces retiring in 2019 as the chief of
general staff since leaving taiwan's
military he's advocated for the island
to focus on smaller widely distributed
defenses rather than attempting to match
China's offensive capabilities we have
to change the of all thinking about the
how to build up our capability if the
China really wants to invade Taiwan I
believed he should be very confident for
their a2ad capability
a2ad or anti-access area denial is the
ability to control access to a military
operation Zone usually using long-range
missiles to threaten any enemy forces
that try to enter an area a version of
this was seen last year with Chinese
military exercises that simulated a
blockade of Taiwan live fire drills were
carried out in six zones blocking
Maritime traffic in those areas and
ballistic missiles were fired into
Waters off the Islands East Coast
Admiral Lee says China would only
attempt an invasion of the island if
they were confident that their a2ad
capabilities would block a taiwan's East
robustly enough to dissuade taiwan's
allies from coming to its assistance no
one will give you a guarantee that they
will be here to Aid if there is war
across the streets so instead of
investing in large Conventional Weapons
like tanks and warships Lisa's Taiwan
should focus on mobile and civilian
capabilities
such as portable anti-ship and anti-air
missiles drones and radar systems that
could make an invasion too challenging
for China to even attempt I believe that
the asymmetrical Warfare is the key for
the weaker side or for the smaller one
in the early stage of the Ukraine war
Russia used a lot of the tanks or armor
vehicle try to direct the uh attack the
key but it's about because the Ukraine
has a lot of the small asymmetrical
arms like the Stinger or Javelin or an
aw and while Taiwan is building its
supply of smaller arms experts say it
will still need to rely on the
assistance of its allies who are
increasingly signaling their willingness
to defend the island the new U.S access
to joint military bases in the
Philippines could play a key role in
taiwan's East Coast strategy these new
bases are located on the other side of
the Bashi Channel a key access point for
the Navies of both China and the US and
an important Maritime traffic Route some
U.S systems including hymas could reach
the south of Taiwan if placed on the
other side of the channel allowing them
to strike back against the Chinese
Invasion attempt remotely and while
China's movements in the East have made
some experts concerned about the
Island's current strategy others say
Taiwan already has the capabilities it
needs to stop China from rounding the
island in the event of an invasion
increase time you can let the POS Open
or worship to go along the Taiwan
however in the wartime is another
situation we have the right to defend
ourselves Dr Seuss is a director of
taiwan's Institute for National Defense
and security research I think tank
funded by the Ireland's military he says
watching the war in Ukraine has made it
clear that Taiwan has some advantages in
the event of an invasion attempt you
know Ukraine is a so-called Ground
Battle for you however in Taiwan case
it's a maritime battle so Taiwan can use
limited resources to create a so-called
design Zone to blockage POS Navy or
their Air Force to enter is the side of
Taiwan
so to do this Taiwan is also investing
in larger defensive systems like the
Patriot and Felons a cannon mounted on
Military vessels used to stop incoming
threats
taiwan's defense Ministry said in
earlier remarks that it won't entirely
rely on its East Coast to be a safe
haven in the event of a conflict saying
there will be no clear distinction
between the front lines and the rear
during wartime while China continues to
Signal its capabilities to take over
Taiwan by force if necessary the island
is increasingly using its own war games
and exercises to show Beijing and the
world that it's able to defend itself I
hope all defense can tell the China side
can tell POA don't invade us if you
invade
you will suffer lots of the casualty and
you are not able to occupy the Taiwan
physically
so that they will think twice
but even as they debate how best to
repel an assault the Taiwanese Military
Circle agree but the best case scenario
is to avoid any conflict in the strait
foreign